kind of hurts to look at all right thank
you nate appreciate that so if your kids
are going a bit stir crazy right now
here on summer break there's a really
cool event coming to tivoli village in
summerlin it's called summer pop fest
party box
one of the companies hosting this and we
have the founder jenna rose hunter
joining us today hey jenna it's great to
have you
thank you so much for having me alex
this is so exciting thank you
it is exciting you know i was reading
all about this earlier jenna it sounds
so fun what do you guys have planned
yes we are so excited again like you
said this is an event that was created
by party box
simply bouncing and simply creative
events where women
owned businesses and we just wanted to
create a really fun
and vibrant community pop-up vent with a
festival
feel and just provide lots of
entertainment for children while
connecting our community with some
awesome local vendors and small
businesses
that we've been networking with here in
las vegas jenna i was looking at some of
the stuff you guys have
planned you have a paragraph of stuff
tell us what you have for the kiddos
next weekend
yes so we're going to have beautiful
luxury white
bouncers they're going to be beautifully
decorated we're going to have a ball pit
for the kids
we're going to have umbrella picnic
table setups that is going to feature
some great crafts for the kids as well
fun music we're going to have beach
balls in the bouncers
we're just looking to have just a great
time and the local vendors that we've
brought on to this event they're truly
incredible there's going to be lots of
yummy treats
and also food and ice cream and shaved
ice and popsicles and just all kinds of
goodies
how cool so jenna this is the first
annual
how did this come together is this
coming out of the pandemic and needing
to keep the kids entertained
yes exactly we wanted to create
something we just feel like this year
has been so hard for everybody with
isolation and polarization
and so we just wanted to create a really
unique and fun community
event that just brought the community
together and just
allowed us to just interact and connect
with family and friends and community
members in a fun and unique way
well you guys did it jenna it's coming
up next saturday it's the 17th
nine a.m to 1 p.m in tivoli how much are
tickets and where can people find them
yes so tickets are 15 per child we do
ask that you do have an accompanying
child with you to
enter the event and also you can get
your tickets
on eventbrite are you okay okay
i'm really excited about this you can
get your tickets on eventbrite and
eventbrite.com you can simply search for
summer pop fest
you can also follow party box on our
social media platforms which is
instagram
and facebook the link is in the bio you
can search for summer pop fest on
facebook as well
jenna we have boxes that we stand on
here in our studio and sometimes
they're a little shorter than you think
they are thank you so much for being
with us you guys have a great event nice
to talk to you
thank you so much for having us enjoy it
thank you all right kendall over to